there's no room for social distance when
you're under arrest
maybe 100,000 people have died and you
are on the way to get tested and you're
spitting at the police officer how
disgusting
and you're a sister you saw and observe
the hijab we know nobody's perfect
bu Bravo at least I'm the
[Music]
city
so high limo feed the power
[Music]
this journey this road that I travel on
it all seems crazy over the years up in
2002 Tagalongs inspired by my story from
a juvenile where my clothes had holes in
them
I'm afro is picky - the night east
maschino a Musashi it's no Lacey's inner
Archie's new millennium she was on her
way to get tested for coded 19 it all
started when she was pulled over at
Green acre accused of driving at a
hundred and twenty kilometres an hour in
a 50 zone there's no room for social
distance when you're under arrest okay
so the first thing that we can realize
and see is that she's driving over the
limit which is dangerous
yeah you can cause harm to others which
is haram yeah so you can see this is a
sister who's dressed up modestly who
observes the hijab spitting of a police
meeting that's a police officer yes so
that we swirl it without own eyes chase
down and pulled over in Greenacres for
allegedly driving a hundred and twenty
kilometres an hour in a 50 kilometer
zone now 50 kilometres on 120 is nearly
double the speed of that so we can
acknowledge that this person is a
unreasonable person a dangerous person
yeah you're driving let's suppose some
kid jumped in front of you and you hit
that child and that child died how are
you gonna answer along to their
judgement and in Islam is severe
penalties for that
besides that we live in at a time where
people are carrying a virus that's
killing nearly a thousand people are day
just in the UK just in the UK over 50 to
60 or maybe a hundred thousand people
have died and you are on the way to get
tested and you're spitting at the police
officer how disgusting and you're a
sister you someone don't deserve the
hijab we know nobody's perfect be you
brought in a beard I don't care
the point is as a Muslim who wears the
attire you're representing something
you're representing your our religion
your actions do you think that's aiding
Islam do you think the Prophet peace
upon me if he was there watching you
that the guy who's recording you do you
think you'll be doing that would you do
it no you wouldn't what about the one
not the Prophet does witnessing you he's
passed away hallo hallo Selim Allah the
one who's all sealed is seeing what
you're doing
ignoring a red light and a self sign
ignoring the red banner stop Satan let's
see if she stops and regrets and I write
you this handcuffed and then accused of
spitting allegedly an officer's face and
she spit at his face directly this time
again well like if this is not
disgusting I don't know what is what lie
I do not know what is I know what does
the police officer do but like if I was
if I was officer I'll do probably
something worse
police claim be unemployed
twenty-five-year-old told them she was
on her way to the doctor to test for
kovat 19 she was taken from the scene
wearing a mask the officer who was spat
on is now off the frontline for two
weeks and we know bus drivers police
officers people who are trying to serve
serve the people who police officers
already if I'm not mistaken transmitted
the virus because of people behaving
like this me at the bus stops I even
heard the incident of a fireman who was
spit out a couple of times
testing positive for the virus
people are dying the man but you spit in
that when you're driving the car double
the speed going over red light put in
everybody's life in danger why because
you for some reason what the news is
telling us that you was concerned that
you may have the virus so power look at
this mentality yeah and we know under
the a judgement ever ones gonna be
against you no Neffs in FC it's all
about me
you know this not even the day of
judgment upon Allah you fear that you
may have have the virus so if I know let
me get in the car go the double dispise
go through stop signs red lights spit
our officer if I have if I'm tested
positive let me at least give it to him
what kind of a careless
woman sister you are if you're watching
this video you should truly be ashamed
of yourself sister up
disgusting and you should repent allah
subhanaw taala no excuses if they told
us that you had some kind of a
psychological issue when we can say you
know what maybe you know we can't see
nothing the pin is lifted from you
that's a long word Allah is not gonna
say nothing to you
unless you're gonna be tested on their
judgement let alone us that's not the
case and this is not police brutality
let's not get it twisted yeah there's
not police brutality the officer did
exactly what I was done well now you've
got somebody who may have kind of
carrying a virus spitting in my face I
would have headlock that person and
smashed him on the floor no no offense I
don't give a damn if it's a man or a
woman yeah let alone all of the health
hazards you are now putting out there
wearing a uniform that represents Islam
it's like me as a fireman walking and
there's a fire burn and is ever dueling
on fire and I'm just walking people are
shouting help us I'm like no I'm not
going to help they come thinking man why
you went you're a firefighter what I'm
gonna say oh just because I'm wearing a
fire of a fire officer's uniform makes
me a firefighter no you have to if
you're wearing something you're
representing that take the best of your
ability you know we know nobody's
perfect to make mistakes etc but in the
public in the public doing that I don't
know what leaving the force healthy is a
major issue for police just this week
two other officers tasted positive for
the virus now on the officer involved in
this incident is waiting for the results
of his own test how sad house I'll
imagine this man is old it provided for
his family wait he tested positive
because of you what have you passed away
that is murder you know what that means
in Islam if you are found by the judge
Islamic George guilty if that man died
because of that you you will be put to
death of course I do and there at the
front line doing a terrific job
Hannah was treated in hospital for an
injury to her back her lawyer says the
incident comes after a long straw
with anxiety depression and PTSD she has
not tested positive she's not being
tested officers gonna escape with the
spit on his face and god knows what he's
gonna be thinking about Muslims now Iran
of ours so guys I wanted to do a
reaction video to this and what wha hey
we have to we have to call out people
who are brothers and sisters out why
because we can't turn a blind eye Allah
says on the Koran speak the truth even
if against yourself or your kin so even
if it's my dad my mom my grandmother my
sister my wife whoever it is if I see
the wrong I will say - you are wrong you
are wrong it's not matter of you're a
Muslim non-muslim your remote mean or
not mean you know it's irrelevant when
we see evil the Prophet sallallaahu
Selim said if you see evil try to stop
with your hand if not stopping with your
tongue and if not hit in your heart not
only that the person said the lowest
form of a man is to move and an obstacle
in the way of the people move it out the
way when we pressed Allah with his which
is a father the person who said to us do
not obstruct the ways don't cause a
nuisance to people move somewhere to an
place of safety and we know the process
Salim there's a heavy façon remember
that said something along the lines of
believer is the one who's tongue yeah
who people are safe from yeah
and we're talking about tongue the
people that backbiting and you know
slandering etc all that kind of stuff
later on spitting with your tongue to
somebody else I just wanted to do this
video to highlight and tell people who
are watching this Muslim or non-muslim
specifically non-muslims that please do
not take this sister this female that's
wearing the hijab and think that our
religion teaches this our rhythms
totally against this disgusting behavior
we asked the sister repent and for
Muslims do you not forget the Prophet
SAW Allah Salim said are not finish on
this note I have come for nothing but to
perfect or character good adapt good
adapt have good Adam of Allah have good
add up with the messenger have good Adam
good character with the people and have
good add up with yourself meaning don't
think when you look back at the sister I
even say you know what was I have a good
a double myself disgusting you would not
want that for yourself often sisters
hope you guys have benefited from this
to next time assalamu alaikum when a
better catch
may Allah make our face easy in
quarantine and they shall make it
fruitful with our family members
assalamualaikum what happened today we
better get this journey this road that I
travel on it all seems crazy over the
years up in 2002 Tagalongs inspired by
my story from a juvenile where my
clothes had hos enough i'm afro is picky
- the night east
maschino a Musashi ice no laces inner
Archie's new millennium
you